so
my talk for today is front end up
stooling
i'm nika you can find me on twitter and
such gb
uh i posted the slides online for you to
see
i'm the background it have and i have a
blog at
bonniefoot.com
i'm also writing a book it's called a
javascript application design i write
about
processes um
how to write modular applications
that are testable and it comes with
a lot of code samples that are
fully documented that you can look at
uh here's a this can go if you're
interested just go to that url and check
out with it
so for today's talk
i'm going to talk about
the reasons to build
and the development flow
i'm going to talk about
how to
put together development flow that works
for you and which tools you could use
and i'm going to talk about the
different kind of tasks that you can
perform with those tools
also i'm going to talk about modularity
and in particular i'm going to talk
about how to bring a modularity into the
browser
so
the first question i have is why build
and more importantly why build first
rather than somewhere down the line
and the reasons for this
are process productivity and performance
process really means that you are able
to automate
and automation really is all about
reducing
and eliminating repetitive work
and it also means
it also helps you to
reduce human error
for instance if you go to that link
you'll find a story about the company
who
worked on the stock exchange and
they had one guy doing deployments
on nine different boxes and he did it by
hand on each one of those
and they also had
a
code in production that was 10 year old
and they didn't use it
and it was just sitting behind the flag
and they pushed some new code to eight
of those nine instances because he just
forgot one
and um
and uh he
he forgot to deploy that one and the
issue was that the new code was behind
this
old flag that they just changed to do
something else
but in the
ninth box it still did the same thing
and so they started losing money
because they were they were making uh
bad requests
and um
and they tried to figure out what the
issue was and they thought it was in the
new in the new code
so they started rolling that back and
they started losing more and more money
and they went bankrupt in like 30
minutes they lost half a billion dollars
so like i said it reduced you see mr
eliminates repetitive work
an automation is also productivity for
you because if you are automating
you are able to do
continuous development for example
whenever a file changes you run your
tests again or your build again so that
you're able to develop we are going back
and forth
um
and you can also set that up
on the cloud
and do continuous integration
which is pretty much the same thing but
you do it on the cloud and
rather than do it whenever a file
changes in your local system you do it
whenever someone pushes new code to
um to your
github repo for instance
um
and that also enables you to do
uh deployments uh automatically if those
builds pass in the cloud
and there's also performance um
you get almost for free
compiling bundling minifying um
spriting and asset
hashing
which are all um
almost free if you are uh
doing build first and if you're not
you might have to
move things around a little bit to
figure out how exactly to break those
into what you're already doing
um and all of this
gives you faster response times which
means uh
your goal of making humans happier
um will be easier to attain
um
so what tools am i going to talk about
in the old days we just used to have
tools like make
and which were really more of um
general purpose kind of tools and now we
have tools that are more oriented to
front-end developers such as npm grant
gulp
yemen
and a bunch of others right that you
know
probably even know their names
so i'll just focus on npm gulp and grant
but really you should choose your own
tooling and um i'll just talk about
these three because they're the ones
that i use
but you should find
the tools that
fit what you need to do
so grant
grant is a configuration driven build
tool
it's easy to configure you just write a
big json object uh actually it's not
json uh
you just write the big object with maybe
a couple functions or options or
whatever
and you configure the different tasks
which are made into plugins
and there's a whole bunch of clients
there's like thousands of those so
you can write also your own tasks um
because it's just javascript you write
the function and that's a task
um the issue with grunt is that the flow
tends to get two verbose if you're
trying to
do something rather large
in your builds because
to run a single command in your shell
with grant maybe it takes like six lines
of code
and it's not so fast
as the alternatives maybe maybe but
uh the truth is that
during builds unless you are going for
continuous development which you should
is uh
it's not such big of a deal if the build
takes a little longer
so to install grant
all you need to do is have a
package.json file
the the cli and the local
grant
installation and then you have to
create a grant file and i'm going to
show you how to do that using um
by creating a
grant file that turns a few icons into
spreadsheet so here's a grant file that
does nothing
module exports is the comma js syntax
for
exposing an api in a model
and in command js every file is a mile
i'll talk about that a little more later
so here i am loading a
plugin with grant
and i'm initializing it with some
configuration telling it where the icons
are going to be
where the um sprite sheet is going to be
placed and then
where i want the css to be placed too
and i just run grunt sprite and i get my
icons so it looks kind of like this uh
maybe the designer gave me a bunch of
icons and threw them in a directory and
i can just automate the process of
creating this price sheet which maybe in
the old days you would just
um
make it yourself for us your designer to
do that and it was a really painful
process right
um and you can also do way more
complicated stuff with grant
how many of you have used amazon
institute for instance
okay a few
so amazon ec2 is a hosting environment
and you can automate the deployment to
that as well using
grant
i wrote a package for a grant called
grantee c2 which
shots with your access key your secret
access key and a few other things it
allows you to
put together a build process that
is able to spin up new grant instances
in this case for example i'm
i'm building the whole
distribution
i'm making uh here i'm making a
a message for the release in my change
log um
and then the run this issue package will
enable me to prohibition a
um
probably on the amazon ec2 instance with
ancient x now
um the works and then
it will allow me to push to institute
the changes that i made since the last
release with rsync
um
and then it'll just install my
dependencies again
on restore attention x and mpm
and that's it
um i'm not going to make you watch the
whole thing
and then there's gulp which is similar
to grunt but it's code driven so it's a
little leaner you're just writing code
but it still works with this plugin
concept
there's hundreds because it's newer than
grant but it's again just javascript so
you can
really
build your own
gulp tasks the issue with gulp is that
it comes with um
the concept of pipes streams and
asynchronous code
which are all very node concepts and if
you're not an out developer you might
have an issue with that
um but it's faster than grand so there's
that
to install gulp it's pretty much the
same as with grant
you should need the package json gold
locally and globally and that's it
and here i'll show you how to build
something with gulp and gold you create
a gold file and rather than require uh
uh sorry rather than expose an api you
require the api gulp
exposes um so here i'm defining a task
that does nothing
um
and i can easily uh
say okay i'll take this source file
uh pipe that through uglify
in memory
and then push it to
the desk again
and it's really easy to add more stuff
into that because it's using uh streams
um so for instance if i wanted to print
into the console the size i'll just add
a new pipe statement and pipe that
through the um
the corresponding gold plugin and i can
also transform the file using a hair
file for example adding my license
information on the
version of the package
and then i run it with gold build
similarly to grant
npm is a bit different in that it's
script driven
and there's barely any configuration
you can use any npm package that you
want
and it you can write in javascript if
you're
using set in the node environment
um
the issue with that is that bash isn't
so across flat
cross platform but
if you have to
work with windows probably use something
else
um
and it's probably the fastest option of
the three i mentioned
um so like i said there's no
installation for npm run you just need
debugger json file
and then you add the scripts key
and in that object every
key is
a command
so here you could do npm run length
and would use jsen to lend your
directory the cool thing about npm run
is that
um it it's smart enough to figure out
um
if sent is installed locally as a
development dependency for instance
it'll know to look it for it in nel
miles chess and binges and
so you don't need to install json
globally for npm run to work
um so you do npm run length and that's
it
but the point really is that it doesn't
matter which tool you use
um
as long as
it does the job for you and it works for
you
um
and one last thing i wanted to talk
about
was modularity
um
for the last year and a half or so i've
been using npm and
uh and i entered the another community
so to speak and uh i started caring so
much about miles and writing code that
does one thing very well
but one small thing
so
how can we bring that to the browser
well
um
we have common shares right which is the
node module system
um
but we want that in the browser
and that's where browserify comes in
which basically will
convert the command js code into
something the browser can run
so what's common chairs really mayus is
a mile system which says every file is a
model
also have an implicit local scope which
means you don't have to use
word closures and stuff you just
declare variables and if you want to
expose something you have to use the
global.explicit
call
um they can also expose an api like we
saw earlier
uh same module exports something
and my loading
sorry and miles can require our models
using require like this earlier
and my loading is synchronous which
means the
model will be
pulled in
as uh as you require it
and the other difference with our model
systems is that
in
in in this system you
your modules are loaded in code rather
than having to do like using statements
and requiring other assemblies or stuff
like that
so here's a an example comma js file it
declares a local variable
it exports a couple of methods in an api
and then you can require it in um set
the status and print it
you know you will run that as node foo
right
uh but that's that's not how you how do
you bring that to the browser that's
where browserify comes in
browser fine lines require calls meaning
that it'll it'll figure out what you're
trying to require and
bundle everything together into a single
file so that the browser doesn't
who can't make the requests
can work with it
imports no car models to the browser so
it's smart enough to work with util and
hdb and
all of the other car modules in
available to node
non-common shaya smiles can be shimmed
so you don't have to go uh pester the
guys who are writing your favorite
library just because they don't support
require chairs
um you can use
any library you want
with and you just have to shim it which
means you take the
global that they declare and make that
into a module
um and it has access to all of npm right
which means
uh you have you get access to a much
broader
uh
community of javascript packages
it generates source maps which means
uh your development process uh doesn't
get affected
at all
um and you can automate it away with a
little step so
um
that's pretty much it
so
to run uh to
bundle something through browserify uh
you need to use the cli or it has a
programmatic api as well
um and you can do browse certify main
on and
out that to a browser.js file
um and once you run that
uh there you go you have
uh commonjs models in the browser
so to recap
build first rather than later this will
set a foundation for
where where your application looks like
and enable you to do less hack your
stack down
let's hack your staff down the road
make tools work for you rather than
trying to cram your whole process into a
tool that doesn't really fit your needs
and browse certify all the things really
i i believe browser if is even better
than es6 miles
so
moving forward i definitely think this
is something we should be placing more
weight on
and that's all i had thanks
you